gentlemen gears of for the 4th Gears of
War game
it is a shame they didn't officially
call it gear just for me I was a fan of
puns that would have really sold me on
this particular iteration of Gears we
don't talk about judgment this is the
fourth use of war game at PAX myself and
Scott got to play horde mode 3.0 yeah
the latest iteration on horde mode of
course it's so we're talking about horde
mode now because it's it's now like the
title of like a sub-genre or something
right I got type where is it the start
it was just like Gears was the first one
to do it yeah yeah yeah or like to form
a lot it was pretty much an afterthought
I mean or at least it wasn't forefront
for the marketing wasn't totally we've
got this innovative new multiplayer mode
come check out it was like oh and
there's this thing yeah it was like in
caught on it was just like a playlist
and the multiplayer settings it was like
do you want deathmatch or do you want I
think it was right and then there was a
[ __ ] mode or just like it's been well
since I fired up gears to but I remember
it like arriving with very little
fanfare and growing from there right and
we got to play horde more 3.0 which is
with Rod Fergusson
we did longtime director of gears which
was really cool that obviously that man
knows the games for sure and said
certainly helped us actually get to the
the first boss wave at level 10 sounds
like collision to me yeah a little bit
yeah I couldn't [ __ ] talk Rod magazine's
right there god the socks he was
literally keeping us alive fortunately
in this room so we can like talk [ __ ]
now no exactly both John no gotta like
Sogo fell a couple of times okay
we'll get into that in a second and so
yeah Gears of War for horde mode 3.0 I
think the first thing to sort of talk
about with this is that like when the
the gears like deathmatch beta came out
I was kind of like ah it's like it's
very similar to the old one which is
kind of good but also like there's
nothing new that's really bringing me to
this this series needs something new yet
for sure and I was actually quite
surprised about how different horde mode
is this time around yeah and I agree
with you I'm certainly more excited
about horde mode than the traditional
multiplayer because I remember playing
even before the beta I went to a preview
event and gotten hands-on time with this
traditional competitive multiplayer
modes right and was kind of like okay
yeah this feels a bit like older gears
and it's kind of fun via there's nothing
really exciting about it at all
but horde mode was a lot more fun i kind
of instantly connected
with the new idea that they've layered
on top I mean it felt like the Horde
modes I remember and all the emergent
craziness of everything happening around
you but there's a lot more strategy on
top which I really did so this I
connected with way more than what I've
played of the competitive multiplier I
guess the biggest change so far is that
they've straight-up godlike classes
which yeah sort of they have there was
always like spin a weird way like the
old Horde modes were you know it was
such a level playing field because we're
all doing the same thing and then the
only thing that like differentiated
people with skill and this one you've
straight-up godlike roles to play
there's a soldier a sniper Scout a heavy
and an engineer yeah but it speak to one
of those what about the scouter the
engineer what it's really note that like
you are hard selecting the class it's
not like you can like customize your low
like no no no you are picking a class
and what that means is it's different
for every class but a really good
example is like the Scout class so part
of horde mode is building fortifications
and buying weapons and upgrades and
things like that so you need currency to
do that the Scout gets double the amount
of currency of any other character type
when he picks up a power icon which is
like the currency of the games like
energy they kept refer to it or
something else so you get way more
mileage out of each power icon if the
Scout is the person picking it up but
the Scout is the squishy one he's this
what you wanted so that's why it's like
the heavies job and the snipers job to
keep him alive but it's a good example
of how a role impacts the game because
yeah anybody can pick up a power icon
but clearly it works out best for
everyone
if the Scout is the person doing it
because you get double the points or
double the currency for doing that so
yeah then you've got the sniper class
which is pretty obvious
you've got the heavy which can like
spawn with something like a boom shot
which will otherwise just be a pickup
yeah the engineer then is I guess
predominantly building yeah they get a
discount on like everything so kind of
like how does the Scout gets double
currency they engineer anything they
build is cheaper right so you kind of
want that person hanging back by the
fabricator which is a kind of a new it's
basically what you build your base round
at the start of every match a fabricator
spawns you could move it wherever and as
soon as you put it down that's where you
start but that is your one-stop shop for
like upgrades and action you can revive
allies that have died that you didn't
successfully revived during around and
it's also where you purchase all of your
fortifications
so yeah the engineer needs to cutting
out about the fabricator and be buying
stuff so that that you preserve your
currency supply on what type of stuff
for you buying can you remember some of
those cemeteries yeah or means like you
can buy like it at the very basic level
you can buy like barbed wire and fortify
your immediate area but that's like the
really basic you can build turrets which
cost a little bit more by the end you
can be building like oh god I'm turning
over with a really high level stuff was
unfortunately we only got to play the
first 10 waves yes so as a 50 exactly so
traditionally there are 50 waves that
it's true again here every 10th wave is
a boss wave we only played the first ten
so we didn't see a lot of the really
high-level stuff that you can build but
yes suffice to say that as you play you
get more and more powerful options they
just cost more yeah um so yeah you can
really fortify your position and
actually one really good piece of advice
that the rod gave me that I was able to
write about a little later is the first
40 waves you're not just trying to
survive you're trying to prepare for the
final 10 totally because they are far
and away the hardest like by the time
you get to the final 10 waves all
enemies have like two and a half times
hell two and a half times damage two and
a half times accuracy and there's like
bigger boss characters mixed in with the
other characters so the final 10 waves
are just like built it just yet so
there's this weird mechanic where you
can basically like stick weapons in a
locker so yes I do as well sway for
something that comes in if they drop
their weapons you can just like get them
and then actually know what I'm not
confused is now I'm gonna stick it here
yeah so yeah your rod Lee like you know
the little fortification thing that you
create you're sort of like arming ish
and arming it and so that you can use it
I guess like for the the most the best
strategy yeah anyway and what's really
cool oh sorry to me interrupt but just
one last quick thing done Locker it'll
actually reload any weapon that's in it
so yes like a rocket launcher yeah so it
takes a little while but if you have a
rocket launcher and eight rockets and
you fire off seven in older gears games
it's like well you got one left and good
luck but now if you before firing that
left shell off you put it in a gun
locker over time you'll get more Rockets
and get more mileage out of that gun so
again but who's you to pay play
strategically and think about what
you're doing
yeah sorry no I was just saying this all
sounds like really good I mean horde
mode for me was always one of those
things or like I got what people liked
it but for me like maybe a couple hours
in I would feel like just not interested
like okay I got it I just need to kind
of get better but this sounds like you
have a whole range of options to really
just like strategize and change how you
play the game which again this series
really needs that so that's very good to
hear yeah and even then the classes
themselves once you've actually picked
one on the menu it kind of a little bit
deeper maybe for our first run-through
but they had these skill cards
that you basically assigned to your
character which gives you like boosts on
specific weapons or you know gives you
like more energy if you start like I was
the heavy and if I did like a one-on-one
takedown and instead of like shooting
them from afar then I've got like three
times as much energy drop there's just
really cool ones yeah well the nice
thing about those the gear cards is you
assign those before around so you're not
really messing with them like yeah once
you're in the match you're just focusing
on not dying
but it's cool that a lot of those give
you kind of new ways to play and
actually one of things I really like
about the gear cards is they're very
risk/reward there are some really basic
ones that are general that can be
applied to any class but they're they're
kind of less powerful but they're
applicable to anybody and they're easier
to use yeah but then you'll get ones
like the sniper had an explosive
headshot ability right so if you're
confident that you can consistently land
headshots that is a really amazing card
because you do way more damage but it's
also like how confident are you that you
can consistently land a headshot when
there are people like rushing at you so
again kind of a risk reward you get less
out of it if you're not able to actually
like land headshots but when you do it's
a huge bonus yeah so you can decide
ahead of time there's a little bit of
strategy even among the the various
classes I was pleasantly surprised I
feel like it's probably like in a weird
way this requires a bit more teamwork
than the old horde mode kind of did as
well like y'all really need to make sure
you're not like stepping on each other's
toes that was one thing I felt like
especially because the map wasn't that
big than when we played you can see the
gameplay of it now it's we were kind of
all on top of each other for a lot of it
I'm like you know a lot of communication
with like some coming down stairs so I'm
coming from the the red barn totally am
going and I can't imagine that like by
the end there's probably a lot more you
know not ten rain oh god again we this
was the first 10 rounds by the end I'm
sure would be screaming our heads off
yeah cautiously optimistic about horde
mode well you think Peter just been like
listening to us talking about it I guess
it's like what you know I guess said a
second ago like this sounds like a great
sort of injection like shot in the arm
for this series because I kind of like
him like I like the environment and like
the setting and some of the story for
the gear series but I always would maybe
play the campaign and then put it aside
this actually sounds like I may like
this better than the main game that I've
my only basis for that is that this
sounds really interesting
so I'm curious to see how this maybe
impacts that
balance of where there you know the
Coalition is paying a lot of their
efforts during development
yeah for sure I've seen a lot of
excitement just in the comments and the
articles we've been putting up people
saying like yeah I plug play gears for
horde mode and one thing I also
mentioned in our impressions video I
appreciate that this is a very like true
horde mode it is like a small area and
they're waves of enemies because the the
next like the other really big kind of
horde mode ish thing I can really think
of is call of duty zombies mode which
has evolved so much that it's not really
a horde mode anymore like you're
actually running through a level it's
not really a point defense or like
tactical thing anymore
so I appreciate this is very like back
to roots but with some new stuff layered
on top it seems like a really smart
approach with how they're doing it I'm
sure yeah you can learn more about Gears
of War 3 sorry for television folks in
Gears of War 4 it's a little confused
oh hold on your butts coming to you
sometime soon didn't check the release
date oh well October 11 fired October
tough thank you Scott literally you can
check out more about it with Scotts it
was October 11th 11th or 11th coming to
you this October Halloween it's just in
time for Halloween and Valentine's Day
alright